hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll you
are of course listening to a podcast at
this very moment and there's a lot of
podcasts out there in the world you
might have noticed doing very different
things different kinds of approaches
different kinds of subject matter here
is something common to all of the
podcasts that I know about they are
produced by human beings there are no
non-human animals that have their own
podcasts at least not without help from
regular old human beings there's
something special about human beings
something that makes us different from
other animals and I say that with great
caution because of course there's an
enormous amount that is common between
human beings and other animals and you
have to say other animals because we are
animals we are part of that Heritage we
share enormous amounts of DNA and
functionality with other animals
especially the great apes the our
closest genetic relatives but also we
are different in some ways so so I think
it's easy to over emphasize either the
similarities or the differences there's
a spectrum but we're at one end of the
spectrum and so rather than just saying
we're the same or we're different the
interesting thing is to see exactly how
we are and compare it to exactly how
other animals are and tease out both the
similarities and the differences so one
of the leading researchers in this area
is Michael tomasello today's guest he is
a psychologist probably if you had to
pick something that's what you would
call him but if you look at his academic
appointments at Duke where he is located
he's in the Psychology and Neuroscience
Department also in the evolutionary
anthropology department and also in the
philosophy department so he is spanning
these different areas and one of the
great things about Michael's work is
that it's very empirical he's doing
experiments and he's doing experiments
comparatively between great apes and
human beings especially young human
beings you might expect to have the most
in common with our primate relatives and
he has a theory he has lots of theories
he has lots of ideas that uh he's
exploring but he cares about what makes
human beings different and he puts his
finger on our sociability
our ability to have social interactions
of a particular kind I mean you remember
we talked to Adam bully very recently
and and he and his collaborators have
this idea that our ability to imagine
the future and do mental time travel is
crucial to what makes humans different
and I think that that absolutely is a
plausible Theory but then what are the
ways in which we become different and so
Michael tomasello wants to say it's how
we interact with each other of course
other animals also interact and have
social webs in which they move but there
is something about human beings that
enables cooperation morality obligation
in ways that seems to be special his new
book is called the evolution of agency
from lizards to humans and he points out
right in the podcast that the word
lizards is very intentional there in the
title because usually his research does
not involve lizards doesn't go back that
far but there was some I idea that
agency the idea of a person being able
to act for reasons uh has evolved over a
very very long time and that's part of
what makes us special that that sort of
intersection and interplay between
individuality and the group dynamic and
how we come together so lots of good
stuff from one of the leading thinkers
out there let's go
[Music]
Michael Thomas hello welcome to the
mindscape podcast yeah hi Sean thank you
one of the things I love about your work
is that you're interested in the
differences between human beings and
other great apes uh and therefore you
study both you study you know children
in development and also apes and so tell
us a little bit about the the
methodology of doing those things I
presume it's very different uh and are
you ever like very surprised by
similarities or differences that you
find
well I think one of the reasons that
people find uh the work interesting is
because
um we're always thinking about how we're
similar to animals and how we're
different the ancient Greeks already
thought like that and I know from
talking to non-academic friends and
stuff people find it interesting what a
chimps do that's similar to us what do
they do this different so I think it's
kind of inherently interesting so that's
um that makes it a little bit easy or to
sell
um so in terms of methodology it sort of
started out
um
where um we would do a study with kids
and we'd say well let's try it with
chimps also and they would be two
different studies and we started with
gestural communication and we looked at
chimps for things that looked like kids
gestures like maybe like pointing or
something like that
and then you know I don't know exactly
where the idea came from but I said well
let's just you know put them in exactly
the same situation as much as that's
possible and see what happens and uh we
use the we used a metaphor at that point
uh let's turn up the microscope uh you
know meaning from the beginning make
them as similar as possible
um and I knew from the beginning that
there's a whole contingent of people out
there who really don't like saying how
great apes are different from humans
they want they want to stress how
similar we are I'm an evolutionist I
take similarity for granted I take
continuity for granted we're only six
million years separated from them ten
fingers ten toes I mean you know uh uh
we perceive the world the same way uh
you know interact with one another in
lots of similar way so I take similarity
for granted continuity for granted
but people don't want to see any
differences at all and my colleagues
like Franz DeWall and Christoph Bosch
who are always stressing similarities I
say
okay if you don't like my story please
um you know tell me a better story about
what makes humans different and you know
I mean we have basically won the large
mammal competition all the other large
mammals are under our control we can
wipe them out or keep them alive as we
please so there must be something going
on
um and all I can ever get out of them is
language but I have a whole book trying
to show that language presupposes
a lot of social cognitive things a lot
of theory of Mindy kind of things a lot
of Cooperative we share information with
one another cooperatively in a way that
other Apes don't we I I tell you stuff
for your benefit I share stuff with you
just to share it just gossiping and
whatnot
so there are different
social cognitive mechanisms different
motivations underlying language that are
much deeper and that's where I get to
the shared intentionality business and
language is an outgrowth of that
so anyway the whole point of going off
on that little tangent was to say that
those people I knew they would criticize
the experiments for not having exactly
the same methods because they can't be
exactly the same yeah all right and so
um we did every time we designed one of
those studies we
did our very best uh to make them the
same and then in addition we had control
conditions and this is really important
because some of the I mean control
conditions are you know a basic part of
science uh from introductory class on
scientific methods but
um uh
Christoph Bosh in particular who's not
an experimentalist but as a field worker
uh has never appreciated for example
people say well you know there's a human
experimenter and that matches the
species of the children and it's a
different species for The Chimps
but we might do a study where
um where we
um you know like if we're
we're gonna um hide some food from the
chimps and we kind of you know maybe
lift it up a little bit or we do
something and then they find it but then
we point to it this is one of the places
where they surprisingly fail and we
point to it like this and they don't
find it Well the human experimenter was
the same
in both the control condition and the
experimental condition so if it was
going to affect it it would affect them
in both
so
um and then on top of it
children find it uh that particular test
just as an example they find it quite
trivially easy from infancy so
so this is what I call a good negative
because as we know in science
negative findings meaning a non-finding
no not different from chance
could be due to anything and uh so
um
you don't know but what I call a good
negative is that the chimps pass a
control condition that's very similar to
the experimental condition that's only a
little bit different and kids in the
same as close to this identical
methodology as possible they pass and
that to me
um sets uh the the chimp failure in the
key condition in um in in a in a um it
makes it a meaningful uh fact it's
meaningful that they don't do it so you
asked me about the methodology so I was
just saying we try to make it as similar
as possible uh but um of course it's not
identical but then we try to take care
of that with control conditions and and
we see if human children can do the same
thing we did have Francois on the
podcast and it is uh fascinating
research but I take the point we're
always slightly amazed when we find uh
other primates showing at empathy or
altruism or something like that that we
think about as quintessentially human
and we emphasize the similarity there
but in some sense there is something
obviously different there are no
chimpanzees who have podcasts or who use
laptop computers so there's clearly a
question to be addressed here right
uh every species by definition every
species is unique in some way yeah right
so we're not we're not saying anything
and humans would seem obviously you know
we have
skyscrapers and podcasts and computers
and language and social institutions uh
in universities and governments and
Mathematics and so you know we are
clearly what makes us different is
clearly some kind of cognitive thing uh
but at the same time part of my shtick
has been
um that uh the the really unique
cognitive part is intimately bound up
with the unique social part that that
what we do is uh put our heads together
with others and I've from my very
earliest things I've used the um
uh the thought experiment of the child
on a desert island who
um uh grows up without any other human
beings from birth with no other human
beings you know what mathematics would
they invent I feel like they would do
pretty much what chimps would do right
so chimps can already quantify things
and tell which one has more and things
like that uh what would what would you
invent on your own beyond that
well sir you know maybe little I don't
know what but certainly not algebra
let's put it that way uh and would you
invent a language by yourself that makes
no sense there's nobody to talk to you
wouldn't invent a language by yourself
and you certainly wouldn't invent a
social institution or any of this
complexity by yourself so this is the
key diagnostic feature is that humans
are not doing this on based on
individual brain power they are adapted
to leverage to use that metaphor to you
know what other people know and and
collaborating with others and
communicating with others and socially
learning from others and of course
culture is built up to actually teach
others
and so that's really uh the difference
so
um uh if you you know if you raise the
Chimp on a desert island and the kid on
a desert island they wouldn't end up
that different but uh humans are adapted
but then you raise a chimp in a human
culture which people have done in
various ways and they maybe are you know
are a little bit different but they're
pretty much still Tim's and and kids in
a culture are you know doing all these
um human-like things so so clearly there
is so I mean let's just let's just get
the claim very very clear
um other great apes which means I guess
what chimps orangutans and gorillas is
that right uh and bonobos and bonobos
right so they have some kind of social
skills but you're saying that there is a
special kind of social skill and we'll
fill in the details but there's
something special uh about how human
beings interact with each other that
does differentiate them from these other
great apes very very good yes precisely
and clearly there has to be something by
a lot logical there also because like
you say you can't bring the chimp into a
house and raise it and it'll just be
human
that's correct so good so our Quest is
is clearly defined now we want to figure
out and you if you want another
indication of the biological part of it
is you have children with autism is the
is the syndrome they tend to be missing
exactly the things that um
um that I'm trying that I'm zeroing in
on right of course autism is very
complicated because it is a spectrum and
you get people who are very and so that
that but it is a good thing to point out
that we can uh that you know ultimately
there are both the differences and we're
both
suffused with commonalities and that's
okay we want to get exactly the nuances
right
that's correct so okay then
um
you know I've often in my simplistic
physicist way been asked you know is it
possible that human beings would ever be
able to understand the ultimate laws of
physics and I have a line for that but
you're the right person to ask whether
my line is at all right which is that we
did undergo some kind of phase
transition in human cognition where we
can manipulate symbols and I almost want
to say it's like going from A Primitive
computer to a touring machine where
we've reached a level of abstraction
where yeah I don't see any obstacles to
us figuring out everything eventually I
mean Nature has to cooperate but there's
a different kind of cognition going on
at the symbolic manipulation level in
human beings than in other Apes
I agree with that but I would say that
your child on a desert island uh uh
they're not going to learn a language
right there is no language to learn uh
there's nobody to communicate with are
they going to be similar symbol
manipulators like that right so okay so
so the brain has evolved to do all of
that in interaction with others that's
uh and I think
um you know getting other people's uh
other people disagreeing with you and
you having to take their perspective
leads us to one of the things that I
think is taken for granted in much of
adult cognitive science is that we can
look at an object and say you know
that's a dog that's an animal it's a
thing it's a pet
no problem Call It Whatever you you know
whatever's appropriate well I don't
think other creatures really have that
kind of flexibility that the same exact
item can be looked at from different
points of view and we all know from a
certain age children know maybe little
children don't really little ones but
from a certain age we know oh it's just
how matter of how you look at it so we
have all this flexibility
um I've even
talked about perspectival cognitive
representations and I think symbolic
the way you're thinking about it and the
way a lot of people are thinking about
it is of that nature when you mean
symbolic you mean a symbol for animal or
a single symbol for dog or a symbol for
pet and uh it's not about the world it's
about our conceptualization of the world
and then we can manipulate those in all
kinds of ways so um I think the
evolution of the species was to be able
to do this in interaction with others
and then actually start my book on the
evolution of human thinking uh with a
metaphor I say um it seems like thinking
is something in the privacy of your own
mind and it and it is but it's like a
jazz musician playing a jazz Rift in his
apartment by himself uh yes he's doing
it by himself but it's he learned Jazz
from other people and the instrument was
built by other people over many years
perfected and he's and he's playing in
the genre that was invented by other
people before him so um so yes we end up
doing all this thinking and and uh and
symbol manipulation uh but if you look
at the evolutionary and cultural history
um uh the individual is growing up and
being assimilated into that and that's
an essential part of the process also so
you mentioned that around six million
years ago is when we diverged uh Homo
sapiens well I guess genus homo should I
say from uh genus homo yes from the
other great apes uh what can we actually
what Gina's homo sorry I I correct that
uh that's when hominins that's the line
leading to humans started uh but it's
only about two to three million years
ago that we want to call them homo so
they were australopithecines and things
back at six million years ago I knew
there was a very small chance I was
going to get that right thank you for
for getting it right so so what do we
what can we confidently say then about
where in this evolutionary trajectory
this little transition happened do we
know
uh uh
um it's a fascinating question and in
that all right so let's take the six
million years yeah
from what we can tell from the fossil
record for the first four million years
or some people might say more like three
or three and a half but somewhere uh
more than half uh we were basically
bipedal Apes all right we were four four
feet tall four and a half feet tall our
brains were the size of apes and we just
happened to walk on the two legs but
there was nothing that seemed to be
different at all then two two and a half
million years ago you start getting
these Stone to schools but they're not
very sophisticated right and chimps
already use stones to crack open nuts
they don't fashion the stones but they
know how to use stones and so you start
getting something new and then two
million years ago you start getting a
little brain growth it looks like a
little bump uh there and you're getting
this tool use stuff
so it's two million years I think you
can sort of zero in on part of it but if
you take this uh social cultural
hypothesis seriously
um uh and you look at the tools uh it's
really less than a million years ago uh
that you get something that looks like a
collaborative forage and collaborative
hunting for example which I think was a
key transition point and so that's less
than a million years ago perhaps even a
half a million years ago if you if
you're very if you don't allow groups
Scavenging and stuff like that
um and uh and then so that's half a
million years ago and then maybe 100 to
000 years ago very recently that's Homo
sapiens sapiens and there's where you
get the idea of really cultural groups
and where different groups have
different tools and uh that's a time
where you might expect to see a
conventional language and things like
that so uh the answer to your question
is when did it happen is
I'm of the view that it was fairly late
yeah and out of the Six Million Years
humans have been on their own trajectory
in the last million
um uh where something really different
happened and and and and I I forgot to
mention that there was also uh another
brain growth spurred around a half a
million years ago so okay I mean it does
seem like a really hard but important
question to say something like the idea
you already mentioned the idea of a
theory of mind the idea that human
individuals not only know things but
know what other people know or have
opinions about it
is it even contemplatable to imagine
saying oh the this point in evolutionary
history is when we developed a theory of
mind
uh well you know it doesn't leave
fossils so no we don't but um uh uh but
chimps already know some things I mean I
I try to avoid the word theory of mine
just because people mean different
things by it but you know one of our one
of our most highly cited studies the one
that really kind of changed my mind I I
originally started out thinking chimps
didn't understand any mental or
psychological states of others but then
we did a study where
um a subordinate chimp and a dominant
chimp are competing for food and the
subordinate chimp can see some food that
the dominant can't see it's on the
subordinate side of a barrier right okay
and the subordinate behaves in ways that
show she knows that dominant can't see
it right right but this is just seeing
this is not sharing thoughts or
disagreeing with opinions all right but
we also have studies showing that they
understand what others goals are so if
they watch somebody else uh trying to
reach a goal and they're not able to
reach the goal they still know what they
were trying to do even though they
didn't see them do it
all right so so
um they have this is sort of Ground Zero
that I think the great apes uh all share
is an understanding of the perception
and goals of other individuals and not
the mental States more narrowly defined
um so there's already a starting point
of that and then that's why I say you
know continuity it's continuity but
continuity doesn't mean identity
um and uh and so I think that what
starts making the difference is when
it's important to me like if we're
collaborating it's important to me that
we're both looking at the antelope over
there but you're seeing it from one side
and I'm seeing it from another and you
have one strategy and I have another
strategy and we've got to coordinate
those and so one of the things that I've
argued in in with children
is this hypothesis that I have about
putting your heads together it's a
necessary feature is something like a
theory of mind but it to be sufficient
it needs to be coordinating with other
people's minds and that's in
communication that's what right when
we're having a conversation we're trying
to you know I I don't understand you you
have to revise yourself you say
something I disagree with you we're
coordinating our minds as we're
communicating and when we're
collaborating we're coordinating not
only our actions but often our decisions
uh do you know in the
um in Game Theory coordination problems
I do but the audience might not so so a
coordination problem is is a problem
where
um we need to do the same thing let's
say we're at a we're at a a rock concert
and it gets out and we and we get lost
from one another and we need to go home
together you know where are we where are
we going to meet well we I think well
okay where where does he think I'm gonna
go well he thinks I'm gonna go where I
think he's going to go and he thinks I'm
going to go where he thinks I'm going to
go so
these coordination problems
um uh require coordinating and
recursively thinking about what he's
thinking about what I'm thinking
um and I think what we've called Joint
attention which you see in young infants
already at about a year old
um where we're looking at something
together and then the infant looks up at
you and then looks down and and we're
coordinating our attention to this
object
um I believe it has a recursive
structure that not only am I looking at
it I know you're looking at it and and I
know that you know I'm looking at it and
and you know that I know you know that
I'm looking at it so uh the sharing
attention and sharing intentions uh and
sharing mental States is about this kind
of what to get away from all the
recursive embedding we just say Common
Ground we have common ground knowledge
we both know that we both know and I
don't think chimps and other primates
have that and I think you once you get
that so you again you're talking about
humans as symbol manipulators and uh and
and re reaching a phase transition with
a no way uh with a new way of thinking I
believe it evolved to coordinate your
thinking with others right with this
taking perspectives uh you know and um
and um
and trying to make what you're thinking
perspicuous for your partner
um one of the things people have asked
me couldn't
couldn't um humans have evolved all this
fancy theory of Mind including recursive
thinking in order to compete with others
so I'm wondering what he thinks I'm
going to do and what I couldn't be
competing and in theory it could be but
the thing about cooperating is I want
you to read my mind if we're if we're
cooperating yeah I'm trying to make it
if you and I are going to go do
something together I try to tell you
Sean here's what I'm thinking here's my
plan what do you think right and oh wait
a minute wait a minute I changed I'm
going to do something else so I am
trying to facilitate you reading my mind
so I think
um and of course a lot of the
communication we engage in uh I'm just
informing you of things I'm just telling
you things uh that I think will be
helpful to you and especially if we're
collaborating oh you dropped your spear
over there or something like that
um uh again I'm trying to make it easier
for us to read one another's mind and
for us to collaborate uh uh together on
a common goal and you can see why people
would think of language as being so
important here I mean if you want to
communicate to someone else what is in
your mind something pretty intangible
from the outside world the ability to
use language is very helpful there and
so you're not denying the importance of
language you're just saying that it
flows out of this common uh social skill
absolutely and again the book that um
that I wrote on the evolution of all
this uh on the evolution of human human
communication I say there's actually a
halfway point that shows you that it's
about
um that it's not language as a
conventional symbol system uh uh that's
not this first step
we have gestures that are uniquely human
for example pointing and iconic gestures
or pantomime all right uh so if I if if
if you and I are whatever wandering
around out in the woods and I point like
this okay what do I mean well you have
no idea with no context but let's say
you know you and I are deciding we're
going to go hunt antelopes and we both
know from our past experience we know in
our common ground that we need a spear
and we need a wood of a certain type to
make a spear and we're wandering around
and I point over there and you see a
piece of wood like that okay you can
understand that I'm I'm pointing out
that piece of wood to you because it'll
make a good spear for us to do
collaborate together a chimp cannot
communicate in that way pointing is
basically you gloss pointing as look
over there and you'll know what I mean
yeah okay right and and with the same
pointing I can point over there and mean
there's some bear berries there are some
delicious berries I can mean anything
with the pointing but it depends on our
common ground it depends on what we know
in common when you search your search
space like what does he mean when he's
pointing over there it has to be things
that we know in common I wouldn't be I
couldn't be pointing about something I
don't know about and I wouldn't likely
be pointing about something that I knew
you didn't know about so it's things
that we both know about so so that's a
kind of a halfway house to language is
and iconic gestures are symbolic right
so I say you know let's go I make a I
make a a gesture like throwing a spear
to say let's go hunting antelopes where
we throw Spears
not other Apes do not use iconic
gestures either and they're symbolic
already so I'm absolutely I started my
career in developmental psychology with
own language so I am I'm the last person
to say that language is not important uh
but um uh
language is the icing on the cake it's
the jet rocket at the end all right it's
not the starting point and in fact
they're actually
theoretical in principle arguments that
you can't start from nothing and just
say oh okay let's call that a tree
you have you have to have some some I
think you have to have another form of
communication and then you
conventionalize it into a language and
now you've got these conventional
symbols and so forth so anyway so yes I
think language is is critically
important for
um uh for uh many uniquely human uh
things and that's why our child on the
desert island one of the main reasons
that he or she wouldn't get to
fully adult human cognitive capacities
is because they don't have language but
it presupposes a lot of other things and
if you want to say what makes humans
different is language then you've got to
go back and account for those other
things that make it possible and where
would you stand on the question of
whether or not there is an innate
language capacity uh sort of Noam
Chomsky Stephen Pinker point of view
um I wrote a a
um a critique I wrote a bunch of
critiques of it but but uh
um
pinker's book The Language instinct
which was such a sensation I I just said
really if you want to really understand
you have to be a little more precise
he's really saying a generative grammar
Instinct he's saying chomsky's theory is
an instinct and that's what I disagree
with okay all right uh of course we are
biologically
um prepared or biologically evolved to
use a language there's no question but I
believe we're Evol we're evolved to have
certain cognitive capacities to form
Concepts uh to communicate like for
example with pointing and pantomiming
which is not linguistic so that form of
communicative intentions and reading
people's communicative intentions and
recursive thinking and all that so we're
prepared in all those ways we're
prepared to understand other to imitate
other people when they use a piece of
language we're we're prepared to
internalize the language and use it in
our own individual thinking but
chomsky's proposal was about generative
grammar it was about syntax
right and I my The Institute I was that
in Leipzig Germany for many years we had
a Linguistics Department that was
focused on cross-linguistic studies
and
yes there are a lot of commonalities in
the languages of the world with regard
to again the use of Concepts and
communicative intentions and certain
principles of
pragmatics of communication and certain
principles but the actual grammatical
structures are quite different in
different languages so I actually think
that's um that's the least likely thing
to be innate good out of all the aspects
of language yeah okay good I mean I
loved language instincts but I do take
your critique pretty well it's a great
book that there's you know you can you
can you can disagree with something and
it's a he was uh uh he made language
interesting to the general educated
public in a way that nobody really ever
had before so he um it was it's a great
achievement that book uh but I uh and if
you and if you if you just softened it
up in in a few places uh uh and got away
from the Chomsky and thing and talked
about language more generally
um um you know there's a lot of it that
uh that I could agree with and I guess
the other thing that is very similar to
that question is the distinctions
between what you're trying to talk about
and what we normally think of as
evolutionary psychology because you're
both an evolutionist and a psychologist
but you you diverge a little bit from
the the party line in evolutionary
psychology if I'm not wrong
um okay so sometimes people call it
evolutionary psychology with a capital E
and a capital P and I've also called it
I've heard it called high Church uh uh
evolutionary psychology when I started
my department in uh at The Institute in
Leipzig I thought of the name
evolutionary psychology but it was
already taken by a very particular view
so what people call evolutionary
psychology I am an evolutionary
psychologist by by the any normal
meaning of those terms
um but um the tubian cosmetes version of
it has some special
um uh characteristics and from the
beginning they you know they they
started in Cambridge Massachusetts where
Chomsky is and uh they have um this
Chomsky was about language as a module
and it's innate and it's is modular and
so they took this idea of innate and
modular and um and you know tried to see
everything in through those lenses and
uh
I just find it a little bit narrow I
just I don't I don't find it wrong a lot
of their stuff is really fascinating and
really
um uh interesting but
um uh you know when they focus on when
you focus on something like mate Choice
okay I'm all in okay there's something
that's really uh evolutionarily
important obviously is who you mate with
um and uh who you find attractive and
who you mate with and all that can
easily be a little specialized module I
don't have any problem with that but
things like language and culture and
yeah and all those things they just
don't fit the sort of innate modularity
kind of ideas so again if you had a
child on a desert island I keep coming
back to that as my Touchstone
um you can have all the innate modules
you want but you're not going to get
algebra and you're not going to get a
language and you're not going to get all
of these things
um we are adapted to participate in
Social and cultural interactions and to
internalize those into our own thinking
so I don't I just find uh I I wouldn't I
I don't disagree with hardly anything
they do I just think it's very narrow is
there a sense in which the emphases are
a little bit different I mean
evolutionary psychology literature wants
to find an Adaptive explanation for all
sorts of different behaviors whereas
you're more about a single big thing out
of which many uh other things are
flowing
a very interesting and important
question
um
if you have to think about complicated
human complicated species like apes and
humans
you have to think about them as
organized cognitively hierarchically
so
I'm positing that at some point humans
needed to collaborate with one another
to get their food
what do you have to do to be a good
collaborator oh and sorry it's important
that um also there's partner choice that
is uh Partners choose who to collaborate
with right so what do I have to do to be
a good collaborator well I could talk
about that for about an hour right so I
have to have certain cognitive
capacities I have to have certain
communicative capacities because I'm
going to coordinate with my partner I
have to have certain moral capacities
because I'm going to share the spoils
when I really want to take it all myself
I'm going to share the spoils I have to
have all kinds of things for this uh
evolved for this task that I that is
that is directing my Evolution that is
that is selecting me uh and including
the social part so I have to be
concerned about my reputation I have to
be concerned about how other people view
me as a cooperator that means taking
their perspective so all of these things
um I I'm sure you could get down to
somewhere where you could call one of
them an innate module okay but but
they're part of a larger organizational
thing the tubing Cosmetics like to zero
in on the more
um on the more uh
um things lower on the hierarchy that is
on the on the on the um on the
communication I might do or on the
negotiation I might do to share the
spoils or something like that but if you
you need to so when you say I'm looking
for the one big thing I just think that
human you know humans are like great
apes in so many ways I don't think that
in that last million years that
um that we have separate adaptations for
forming social institutions another
adaptation for language another
adaptation for theory of Mind another
adaptation for mathematics another
adaptation all right
I think it's more plausible in if if the
time frame you're talking about is just
a million years or even two
um is that uh we had this yes one of the
things that to be in cosmetes stressed
that
um was really important in Psychology
and that I promote every chance I get
people will say things like um people
who are not very evolutionarily minded
um a psychologists and a lot of
psychologists included will say things
like
um humans evolved to be smarter and to
have bigger brains
and to be in cosmetes
argue really
forcefully and really convincingly that
Evolution doesn't work like that you
have to have a specific problem right
right you have to have a specific
problem
and so they focus on very concrete
problems mate choice or whatever it
might be uh and what I want to say is uh
you have to think about human behavior
as hierarchical and if what's being
what's being I want to say what's being
I'm agreeing with them and I learned
from them
we have a problem and the problem is
collaborating to get food it's just that
that problem has about 50
sub-problems that it brings with it
um and uh and they are both cognitive
problems communicative problems socio
moral problems uh uh all kinds of things
that go with it so so I wouldn't
um uh I would I would stress that it's
not that they have a lot of little
things and I have one big thing I have
one big thing that I think organizes a
lot of little things okay that that
makes a lot of sense and and I I like
the point that we're not the
evolutionary pressure is not to make our
brains bigger if anything it's the other
way around big brains are very expensive
so there has to be some benefit of
having them and the benefit should be
specific not that someday we'll have
podcasts and in addition another you
know I know I know that a lot of people
you know you seem to be a more
broad-minded physicist than uh than most
but I know a lot of people who are more
in the physical sciences and and
hardcore you know the psychology stuff
and Theory minus stuff it all seems very
you know Airy and everything
um
um but another concrete thing you can
point to
um is is
um
how much longer humans ontogeny is than
others Apes so great apes uh as soon as
they wean at about age three or four
they're on their own right and and
they're getting their food on their own
and uh nobody's teaching them anything
right so there's no teaching so they're
they're basically independent agents on
their own
humans uh their studies with
hunter-gatherer groups that that
youngsters don't bring in more calories
than they consume until they're 16 years
old or something
and in the modern world it's longer than
that now yeah I could still have the
credit card you know in their mid-20s I
have the parents credit card in the mid
20s so so they are human this long
dependency
uh has a lot of you were saying the big
brain has a lot of costs it must be
doing something this long dependency is
both dangerous for children they're not
able to defend themselves from predators
or feed themselves for over a decade
uh and it's costly for the parents
because the parents are investing in the
kids when they could be doing something
you know uh more directly productive for
themselves and when I watch chimps in
Africa I went I just did a month of
field work um one time but
um
um uh if a predator is nearby moms are
typically have two youngsters hanging
off of them and when you're scrambling
having two youngsters hanging off of you
and trying to get away from a leopard
that's not good
so
um uh so this long ontogeny is costly
and risky so it must be doing something
right and what it's doing is it's giving
time to learn and and and to socially
coordinate and to become a member of a
culture and uh uh I mean I don't know if
you've ever had Rob Boyd or Joe Henrik
or one of those guys Bill Henrik was on
the show yeah yeah so they would you
know they would stress that
um uh you know humans have spread out
the other great apes mostly live in the
tropics and humans can live in you know
in the Arctic and uh everywhere else and
it's because but but you couldn't do it
yourself if they if somebody dropped you
or me in the Arctic you know we'd last
uh 20 minutes so or if they dropped us
in the middle of the Jungle uh all right
so the people can live in these places
because they accumulate knowledge and
information about these these specific
locations and transmit it culturally uh
over time so the long ontogeny is
clearly uh
built on the fact that the in that
youngsters need a long time to learn
stuff and they need to be protected by
their parents for a long time to get
that done very costly so it must so so
again that that that's a concrete thing
you can point to in physical development
as it were uh um that is suggestive of a
different kind of psychological
um orientation and you mentioned
morality a couple times and I know that
uh you have a whole other book on the
origin of morality and I'm going to
guess that it fits in very well with
this sort of uh social skill development
story yes
yeah well um so um all the way back to
Darwin people have recognized that being
cooperative being nice to others
altruistic
um uh is a problem for Darwin's theory
uh there's a there's a famous uh quip
that um that in in evolutionary biology
the def uh the definition of altruism is
that which cannot evolve right
because because the individuals you're
sacrificing yeah if if I give away if I
want to be a really nice guy and give
away all the food and all the resources
that I gather then I'm not going to be
leaving any children so I'm not going to
be contributing to the Future gene pool
so ever so Darwin got it right everybody
all the individuals have to be looking
out for themselves but cooperation can
be a win-win situation which there are a
lot of people that don't understand this
uh there are a lot of people who think
it's a zero-sum game but there are
there's another minority voice that's
been in in evolutionary theory for all
along
that cooperation can be a win-win
situation and morality
is I Define as the as the human version
of cooperation it's a special version of
Co-op it's a it's a psychology built for
cooperation right because I'm I'm
sacrificing for you I'm being fair and
dividing those resources to include you
and have your concerns equal to my
concerns and those kinds of things but
to make it work it has to be um it has
to um it has to not disadvantage the
individual out of existence that's the
that's the key and so morality is The
Balancing Act
between me keeping my concerns
in mind enough to survive and keeping
your concerns in mind uh and the key
concept so this is
um uh for people who are hardcore
evolutionists this is the key concept
the key concept is interdependence
all right and
um one way you can think about it is um
symbiosis right you have symbiotic you
know about you know symbiotic
relationships between two species both
of them are getting something out of it
right right so the that's the whole
definition of it well in evolutionary
biology symbiosis is used between
species I'm not sure why it's restricted
that way I just want to generalize it
within the species that is I can do
stuff for you that you need and you do
stuff for me that I need and if the
cause you can do you can calculate the
costs and benefits so that so that it
let's say I do here here is an example
that I used to really dramatize it let's
say that um that um
there there's a female is the only
individ there's one female and she's the
only female in the group that will mate
with me okay my mating success is 100
dependent on her now we approach some
food together
what is in my long my long-term genetic
fitness interest
to steal all the food and not let her
get any no because if she dies then I'm
my genes are not going
so because I'm dependent on her
then I need to share with her I need to
look out for her thing if I have a
partner in collaborative foraging that's
my best partner we work well together
we're successful everybody else is kind
of a loser and somehow I don't get along
with him or whatever and now my partner
is sick one night well you know if I
want to be successful hunting the rest
of the week maybe I better get him some
chicken soup or something I better help
him out right so when you're entered if
you look at all the if you if you go on
Google Scholar and and
put in evolution of cooperation all the
all of the top hits are all on uh
computational models of cooperation and
the computational models all ha assume
these kind of independent modules
everybody looking out for their own
interests and and then the only way you
can get cooperation to work is if you
find other Cooperators and all kinds of
green beards and all this but if you
assume that they're living in an
interdependent social network where they
depend on one another
then they're helping one another because
they depend one another and there's this
very simple mathematics to it
um
a guy named Gilbert Roberts again I
don't know exactly your background but
do you know the uh Hamilton Ken
selection so again I do but let's not
assume that the audience does okay so
the so the
um
the kin selection is that you know my
children share my jeans and my brother
shares my jeans and so it's in my
interest for my genetic fitness that I
help my that I help them to a certain
degree now it wouldn't do for me to help
them and die doing it uh because then
I'm not going to have future children
and all that so there's a mathematics
too uh when it's in my long-term genetic
interest
um to help those people that I think
Hamilton had a quip one time about I'd
fall on a hand grenade for uh two
brothers uh four cousins or whatever it
is he's calculating well the
interdependence has exactly the same
formula but you just substitute for it
interdependence instead of uh instead of
genetic relatedness so to the degree
that I am dependent on you I will help
you if if my if in this in the example I
gave where I have a female the only one
who will mate with me uh I'm 100
dependent on her for my genetic fitness
then I'm guessing I need to share a
whole lot of that food with her and
somebody who's just my grooming partner
and you know I can live with a few more
fleas it's not a big deal I depend on
them for grooming but grooming's not a
big deal you know maybe I don't share
with him maybe I share a little bit with
him whatever uh and and of course it's
actually more complicated than that
because all the individuals in my group
I you know somebody might might be my
Coalition partner and my grooming
partner
so I think that most people
um
who see cooperation as still highly
problematic have not quite comprehended
this process of interdependence they
think of of individuals as all competing
with one another all the time and that's
not wrong it's just not of course
there's a level at which that's true I I
started the whole thing by saying you
can't you know be altruistic to to the
point that that you that you sacrificed
your own existence uh but there is a
mathematics uh of of how much I should
help people that I'm dependent on
all right and so the book on morality
starts with interdependence that if you
have interdependent
um uh social if you have a social group
where people where individuals are
interdependent and almost by definition
individuals in a social group are
interdependent on one another I mean why
are they in a social group to start with
the textbook explanation is protection
from predation if you're in a group you
know we we were better off together
so everybody's interdependent to a
little bit if my so if my if my social
group
goes away and dies uh on my own I'm
going to be in trouble if I'm a mammal
for example so I have an interest in
keeping everybody alive a little bit
okay but then there's some individuals
that I really depend on for whatever for
mating for cooperation for grooming
whatever it is right and and so
um uh we start with that kind of um
interdependence but then some species
are more have more interdependencies
than others and so nothing is more
important than getting food I mean food
and mating right those are the those are
the uh the the the key elements in in
evolution
um uh but food
you've got to do it every every few
hours every day you're if you look at
chimps in the wild
they're wandering around foraging for
food that's what they do all day and
maybe they mate on the side and they
have a fight on the side and they groom
on the side but where they go and what
they do is all aimed at getting food and
and primates in particular a lot of them
and great apes they eat fruits and the
fruits only give you energy for a few
hours and then you gotta eat some more
so
um uh so if humans became interdependent
with one another in getting food to a
degree that other primates did not and
this becomes immediate and and
Urgent interdependence I'm ready to go
out and get some food the only kind I
can get is one where I can get
collaboratively uh or the only good kind
certainly the only meat uh and nobody
will collaborate with me
okay what am I gonna do why won't they
collaborate with me because I don't
share at the end all right if we get
something I grab it all myself and I
don't let them have any so everybody
selects against me they don't choose me
as a partner and I'm a goner so that's
the context for the evolution of
morality is this interdependence
cooperation not cooperation out of just
being nice but this interdependent
cooperation where we have to treat one
another fairly we have to cheat one
another with respect in the sense that I
know that you don't have to cooperate
with me you have some other choices
right and not only that but I know that
you need me too to some degree maybe you
have some other choices also but I know
if we're good partners you depend on me
and I depend on you so I have a little
leverage here too
so what's the solution the solution is
well okay let's divide it equally let's
be fair about it so um so I do think
that um
in in the book on morality I distinguish
uh it goes all the way back to the
ancient Greeks the morality of uh of um
uh
sharing and helping and sympathy
and the morality of fairness which is a
more
cognitive rational kind of process the
morality of sympathy that's where Franz
dewal has focused most of his attention
and that I believe is all mammals have
some of it they have their oxytocin and
and and and and their
um the mothers are sacrificing for
Offspring all the time right all right
and and and some species generalize it
you may have seen some of the stuff
about rats helping other rats escape
from cages and stuff so they all they
already have the mechanism for uh for
sacrificing for their offspring and
that's probably evolved with genetic uh
out of out of kin selection uh but then
they just have to generalize the
mechanism to non-kin and uh uh so I
think actually the the sort of helping
and sympathy is widespread in mammals
it's just a matter of how widely do they
use it but the uh morality of fairness
and obligation I have an obligation you
know you sh you helped me last time I
have an obligation to help you this time
we worked equally hard at this foraging
problem so I feel an obligation to share
equally that we do it fairly and equally
so that that's a motivator the sense of
obligation is not the same thing as
being nice uh you know it's it's
something a little bit more and I think
that is what comes from collaborative
foraging
you know I did very recently uh a
related podcast topic with Adam bully I
don't know if you know him he's a
younger guy uh but he's written a book
recently with Thomas sudendorff and
Jonathan redshaw called The Invention of
tomorrow oh yes well I know the
um um sudendorf uh is the one who's been
on that uh singing that song for a
couple of decades so I know the student
door stuff I haven't read that
particular book yeah but the idea that
uh one of the things that really
separates human beings from other
species is mental time travel right the
ability to put ourselves in the future I
really kind of like that perspective it
might be the physicist in me talking in
my interest in time but but everything
that you just said about morality uh
takes that into account in the sense
that you're saying well if I don't do
this thing right now the future is gonna
come back to haunt me and you can
conceptualize that right and we can
conceptualize that in a way that other
animals baby cannot yeah no that's I I
absolutely true and and
um uh that's an important part of the
process the
um there are studies with Apes where
they do
a little bit of planning future planning
uh and they do a little bit of episodic
memory uh it's not nearly to the same
extent as humans um my initial tendency
would be to say it probably somehow is
part of this story of relating to others
and uh that kind of thing but I I don't
have a particular story for exactly how
that works sure but it does uh lead us
exactly into sort of the Capstone of the
conversation which is the idea of agency
which is the focus of your most recent
book you should tell us the title of
your most recent book uh the evolution
of agency uh and I think it says
behavioral organization from lizards to
humans I can never remember my subtitles
because they always change in the
production process so I wanted to get
lizards in there or something like that
because
um I wanted I wanted to convey to people
who know my other books that I'm going a
little bit farther back in evolution
than I have previously so what do you
mean by agency in this context
okay so
um
let me let me just give you start with
an example that's on page one of the
book um so squirrels cash nuts right
they they hide them away and store and
store them for winter and go get them
later that's clearly an evolved Behavior
they that that all squirrels do it the
world over this is part of squirrel
evolved psychology
but if you look at a particular squirrel
at a particular moment with a nut and
he's trying to decide where to cash it
in this landscape I'm saying that
Evolution cannot in principle
tell them what to do it's it can't be
determined like that
and so in general what evolution has
done
and it may be that uh that you can think
of these very simple creatures
one-celled organisms and very simple
creatures it may be that you can think
of them in deterministic way I don't
know I but but the creatures
um that are a little more complicated
what Nature has done is said okay I'm
going to build you in with a lot of
stuff here but then when it comes down
to actually making a decision about what
to do in a particular situation
I'm gonna leave it up to you because I
can't predict I don't know exactly where
the watering hole is in the place you're
born nature doesn't know that ahead of
time the watering holes change
so I'm going to build you with the
capacity to learn where water your
Watering Hole is and to decide when and
how to go there and stuff like that so
um so agency is about
um the
agency evolves when
um there are unpredictabilities and
nature builds in an apparatus for the
individual to deal with those
unpredictabilities through what I call
informed decision making that is looking
around gathering information and making
the best decision that decision is on a
particular occasion is not determined by
Mother Nature what's determined is the
decision-making apparatus that you go to
it with and so but so you need an agent
now a lot of people say oh gosh that
sounds like a homunculus to me right
that somehow but this is why in that
book I start out with Control Systems
right so I think that and this goes back
to the cybernetics the Ross Ashby and
and Norbert Weiner and people like that
they they build these machines and do
this Theory uh showing that if you have
if you have a problem where you need a
machine
that can act autonomously from in from
individuals from humans
um and intelligently it has only one
possible structure and that is it has to
perceive the world it has to have a goal
state that it wants to be the case in
the environment it has to perceive the
environment and see if it matches with
the goal State and if it doesn't it has
to be able to do something to make it so
to make it match so
you you know the classic is the
thermostat right all right so if I want
the room cooler I can go get a fan and
turn on the fan but the fan is dumb
because I just turn it on or off and I'm
the one who decides if it needs to be
cool or not and what to do and all that
but the thermostat it has a thermometer
it senses the temperature right it has a
set goal I set the goal I put it at 72
degrees but it has that goal and it
senses the temperature of the room and
it sees if they match and if it doesn't
then it acts to make it match
um
I I was explaining some of this to my 11
year old daughter a couple of weeks ago
and we were at a we were at a um a
stoplight and she said that stop light
is a dumb machine isn't it and I said it
is because it turns on and off on a
timing and I asked her my 11 year old
ask her how would you make the the the
traffic light more uh intelligent and
she said well it would have to pers it
would have to have a camera that saw
where the cars were and then some
algorithm or something that turns green
where there's the longest line and turn
right it's pretty good so
so what I want to argue is that um
nature invented this homeostasis in the
body is the same thing right the
homeostatic mechanisms that you have a
blood temperature a temperature body
temperature and and that's a set point
and when you get too cold or too hot
your body does things right it the same
model Works in um behavior
um and uh uh again I'm going to say that
it's not homunculus which some people
the more deterministic minded uh people
uh tend to worry about that I make an
analogy to
um 20th early 20th century biology there
was a big debate between people who were
vitalists right and and mechanism and
the vitalist said okay living things
have a vital substance that makes them
different
right and that's a kind of a homunculus
if you will okay if I and it turns out
that's not true turns out living things
are made out of the same stuff as
everything else but it's organized
in a different way
so I want to say that there's nothing
homunculus that control systems show you
the a certain kind of organization that
the organism has in relation to its
environment that their their behavioral
decision making is organized in a
certain way
and that's what we want to call
um
an agent the agent is the organism
acting with this kind of uh cognitive
organization that I gather in you know I
have a goal I gather information I
decide what needs to be due to meet to
meet the goal uh and so forth so
um so that's what the agency is it's
it's about the and I would say that
people who
um uh who want to say that everything is
deterministic in the world you know the
laplacian uh the starting State and
everything's determined
they just don't want psychology in the
picture I want to say that if you want
psychology in the picture you have to
have an individual making decisions and
if you don't then it's fine but it's all
physics or it's all biology and I'm a
psychologist and I want psychology and
the psychology means I am an individual
who's assessing the situation and
deciding what to do uh to to meet its
goals so
um people kind of that's I don't think I
mean it is controversial to some people
but I would say most psychology kind of
operates with that as a kind of an
assumption but in the field of animal
behavior and I actually wrote the book
on Agency for people in animal behavior
there's still a lot of kind of
um behavioristic talk like stimulus and
response the organism is responding to a
stimulus well that's a kind of a classic
physicalistic cause leads to effect
stimulus leads to response I want to say
no the organism has a goal it's pursuing
and and when it perceives something that
you're calling us stimulus they're
seeing that it doesn't match their goal
and so they're acting to do right so you
you need to think of a circular
causality of the cybernetic type of the
control system type and even in a case
where so there may be things like
reflexes right so a a small object comes
toward my eye and I blink okay I'm
willing to give you that for a stimulus
response all right uh but um but
anything that's you know that we that we
think of as intelligent autonomous
Behavior what defines it is a certain
organization and I want to call it agent
of organization control system
organization and what I do in the book
is Step through different kinds of
control system organization the key
variable being how much executive
control do you have so very simple
organisms are simple control systems but
then when you get to things like mammals
they've got an executive control system
that can plan ahead uh that can consider
different possibilities before acting
and that can get feedback from its
actions and and learn and adjust and so
forth right and then where I get to my
my work um that we talked about for most
of our podcast here the shared
intentionality is that humans have
evolved to be shared agents or social
agents or plural agents all these are
words different people have used and
when you and I decide to solve a problem
when you and I are going hunting
together collaboratively we have a
shared goal we have a joint goal we have
shared knowledge about the situation and
we communicate to make sure we have
shared knowledge
um and uh um and we we kind of
self-regulate it together so I say hey
look over there don't do this you say oh
don't do that do this you know and so
we're kind of regulating it so we kind
of make a shared agent and I've used the
word Sheridan functionality in most of
my uh work until recently and it's the
same thing but shared agency is the
behavioral side the actual collaborative
to solve a problem and share
intentionality is kind of underlying
cognitive capacities that allow the the
shared agency to work
um but anyway so that's what the idea
for the book was I've always had this
control system view all the way back to
my earliest stuff I've never really
elaborated it and so I wanted to
elaborate the control system view in the
context of the sort of
arguing that psychology is important in
evolution because organisms making
decisions and um and that I can scale
that all the way up to humans by talking
about shared agency and by the way
Darwin uh uses the word agency he
actually says that the agency of
organisms is a factor in their evolution
because
um I give an example in the book where
let's say
oh I'm a lizard or something and I
usually get insects on the ground and
all of a sudden something wipes all
those out and they don't exist anymore
and now the only insects are the ones
that are up in the trees and some
lizards are capable of climbing the tree
and getting the getting the new insects
and others aren't so those are the ones
that survive so and and they have uh
made a choice to go up the tree and
capture these guys other guys have not
and so their actual behavior
is leading the way so now for example
those guys may grow longer claws so this
is what people sometimes call genetic
assimilation so now the genes follow the
Behavior now I need to be a tree climber
where I didn't before so now long claws
are an advantage so this is again that
hierarchical system if I'm going to be
chasing insects in trees I need to grow
long claws which I wouldn't if I didn't
go up the tree so behavior and agency
can be a Leading Edge in um in the
evolutionary process itself so that's
another dimension of it well the the
different levels is an interesting idea
because when you started in the book
when you started the squirrel example I
thought you were going to put squirrels
on the non-agentive side of things and
human beings on the agent of side but
you're saying that in a sense a squirrel
is an agent has to figure out where to
put its cache of nuts but you couldn't
sit down with the squirrel and explain
oh no no this year you don't have to do
that I promise to feed you so that
that's the kind of agency that it
doesn't have that's correct and and so I
I have I I have a you know this typology
of sort of three types of individual
agency and then the shared agency that
humans have and and and this again this
I think
um uh actually
um uh
fits with this my from the very
beginning we started with the idea that
um yes humans are continuous with other
creatures and and there has been this
building up of stuff over Evolution that
gets us to humans
um and humans just add this one little
twist
I I'm fascinated by the idea of goals
and as they appear here because it again
and I don't have a strong feeling about
what to say but you know we have an
arrow of time we remember the past and
we closely influence the future and it's
always fascinating to me how I don't
know if it's human or it probably goes
back way deeper in in evolution but the
when was the first goal when was the
first time that we could have attributed
to a species or an organism the idea
that there's a concept of what I'm
aiming for
uh in the book uh I I punt on some of
the on exactly when that might happen
but I would say that single-celled
organisms bacteria single-celled
organisms and stuff do not have they
don't organisms without a nervous system
probably don't I'm just speculating
probably don't
um and I wanted to I wanted to simplify
my problem I mean I don't know if you
know the Godfrey Smith stuff on octopi
and all that but okay that's really
they're they're off in a different world
I don't know about them all right right
so but on the line to humans the first
vertebrates
uh would have been fish I don't there's
not a lot of research on fish but if you
now go to the first land vertebrates
they're like lizard-like creatures
and I think they clearly have goals if
you look at the if you look at research
with lizards
um uh they are trying to achieve goals
and you put them in experimental
situations and you can see that so I
don't know where the first one was but I
feel confident that from vertebrates on
uh they do and um
um I don't you know they're these guys
off to the side like um insects and
octopus and all that sort of stuff and I
just I'm I'm I don't know about them
that's very very fair uh what are your
feelings about free will
uh so the the agency book basically is
saying
um
uh that you have to
um the decision-making apparatus is
evolved you don't have a choice about
whether to have that apparatus or not
right but given that apparatus yes the
individual has free will to choose
within that uh within that um thing now
I don't have a free will to choose
whether to Blink my eye when a small
object comes toward it so not in all of
my behaviors
um
but you know um um humans can starve
themselves to death or commit suicide or
whatever so uh
um to me
people who want to deny Free Will are
essentially taking
um uh a kind of a physicist view of of
psychology right that somehow this this
is like you know you know planets
attracting one another or atoms
attracting one another or whatever
uh I'm saying no the world is a
multifarious place and there's a and
there are creatures that are agitive
that make decisions and they have
evolved in apparatus uh uh to do it so
if you want to say it's deterministic in
the sense that the apparatus for doing
it is deterministic uh then fine if you
want to say the criteria they take into
account when the when the squirrel is
deciding uh about where to cash the nut
he probably doesn't take into account uh
you know the temperature or the wind
direction or whatever you know they're
so what is relevant to the decision
might possibly be uh part of the
deterministic thing but unless you want
to eliminate psychology you need that
individual making the decision and it's
not a homunculus it's a it's just
organized as a control system that's all
and so that's uh yeah that's and I would
just say also that anyone who denies
free will
is just doing it as an intellectual
exercise because
um they themselves if you really didn't
think people had Free Will you'd never
get angry at anybody yeah you never get
angry at your wife for not doing
something because uh well she can't help
herself right and uh and and you
yourself would never you know uh uh
worry about a decision because you know
it's all determined anyway so I think in
their everyday lives nobody believes it
I'm pro-free will myself I did have
Robert sapolski on the podcast and uh
you know he did his best to convince me
that it was all a myth but if you
haven't read it or you're not familiar
with it I would recommend a book by
Janine Ismail who's a philosopher she
wrote a book called How physics makes us
free it's very much in the spirit of
your sort of uh control theory way of
thinking about things recursion the
difficulty of fitting ourselves into our
physical description of the world you
know the Practical difficulty and that's
what makes it hard to really in any uh
any even semi-plausible sense to be a
determinist about the macroscopic world
of Human Experience yeah so there's a
book
um by um Christian list uh yeah called
uh Hawaii Free Will is real and he
basically
um is saying like I am that um uh
the tendency to want to deny Free Will
is to look at things from one
perspective from this sort of you know
deterministic physical perspective
physicist perspective but the but if you
just keep your levels straight uh you
know we're on the level that we work on
that that that that that Robert sapolski
works on every day when he decides what
shirt to put on uh uh you know that
that's
um if he wants to say what shirt he puts
on this morning is determined determined
fine but that he doesn't really believe
that that's just uh you know I get it I
wrote a book about that too I I'm on
your side very much
um so maybe like you know to finally
wrap things up um leading from the
different levels of agency you have sort
of a provocative thought in the book
about
uh increasing complexity along this
chain leads to not only different kinds
of agency but different kinds of
experience you know different kinds of
I don't know uh you know mental
relationship to reality uh well this
this is this is a very long and
difficult uh topic Sean that I'm in a
clear minority on but um I believe if
you are an evolutionist
um you have to you know what is the
world do you know Von UK's call at all
he was a classic anyway uh what is the
world for a worm you know what is the
world for a tick I don't know but I
think that's a good question has a big
uh a big thing about ticks because he he
studied ticks you know and they and they
and and they they basically just sense
the temperature of the of a mammal
walking by or whatever the the the
right so
is it the case that they have their
restricted Little World worms only are
below ground and whatever and the ticks
are only sensing temperature but we
humans have access to the the real world
the way it really is aren't we lucky
we have our world that's determined by
this uh evolutionary process by our
agentive system as well uh and by what
things are relevant to our agent of
decision making
um when we make decisions we expand the
world for things that are relevant we
pay attention for things that are
relevant to our decisions
and
so I I just think that um
you know the general idea of an
ecological niche that's a that's an
everyday Common Sense idea that animals
live in different ecological niches fish
live in water in the same Forest you
know squirrels live in the with leaves
and trees and the worms live under the
ground and the butterflies Thrive
through the sky so they live in sort of
different worlds in the even that's
their ecological niche well
I use the term experiential Niche the
experiential Niche is the world as you
perceive and understand it which evolve
to support your agent of actions in it
and humans even though
even though we like to think differently
humans are the same now part of our
ecology part of our experiential
um Niche is
the mental world of the other people
we're dealing with and the cultural
world into which we're born and the
normative World about the way things
ought to be you're talking about the the
mental time travel one part of mental
time travel is the way things ought to
be yep right and so uh
no other creature I don't think I could
be wrong but no other creature uh you
know plans its actions and behaves with
respect to what ought to be the case
uh so this is the human world so
um I would just say that um it's harder
to see in the case of humans and maybe a
little easier to see in the case of
other creatures but I would say
um that the that organisms experience
those things they need to experience uh
to get done what they need to get done
you know I did talk to Ed young uh and
he had wrote a wonderful book about the
different umvelt the different kinds of
animals have because of their sensory
capacity capacities I I am sad that I
didn't think myself to think about the
experiential
umbelt and how uh you know the normative
versus present future everything going
on yeah it's a there's there's layers
here that it's very fascinating to think
about but the worm is not living in that
world I'm sorry it's not okay now no we
say oh where we're living in the real
world and the worm is living in some
subset
Maybe
no but there's certainly animals that
can sense things that we don't so yeah
absolutely yeah absolutely that's a
Thomas Nagel's famous what is it like to
be a bat right right right so we still
don't know but we're we're learning I
think you've helped us a lot in uh in
thinking about why we're slightly
different and okay here's the final
question
if this is the hierarchy uh of of our
evolutionary Advance
um with our with our increased
capacities is there another future
advance that uh super intelligences or
anything like that might might get to
yeah I don't know about that I don't
know about it either this might be over
my pay grade
I I would say sort of um uh right now
the challenge for humans is
um is more on the cooperation realm
we're going to blow ourselves up or
we're going to degrade the environment
to the degree that we can't live in
anymore or something like that so it's
the Cooperative challenge we have to
meet uh and if we can you know find a
way to meet that uh first uh you know
then maybe we can do some more cognitive
things but um
um uh I will say that I think that you
know once you start getting
civilizations like
um take Western Civilization from
Mesopotamia and Egypt and then ancient
Greek and all that these were guys that
were building up knowledge themselves
and then and they didn't even know the
other guys existed and then they bumped
into one another and a lot of incredible
stuff happened when they bumped into one
another the the Greeks get math from the
you know from the East and I think I
think as as the word if when and if the
world can become more of a world
Community I think that will be a Big
Boon because this this social cultural
process that I'm focusing on will get
another boost uh I mean we do know a lot
there are not many secrets in the world
now I must say with the all the
communication and whatnot but
um but but maybe if we were more
integrated and scientists from different
um uh countries were working together
more
um you know something new might come of
it but first we have to solve the
cooperation problem and uh and all these
um you know
um
nationalistic people who don't want to
cooperate yeah you know at the end of
the podcast we like to let our hair down
and speculate a little bit that's
perfectly good and you've been very uh a
good sport about that so Mike tomasello
thanks very much for being on the
blindscape podcast thank you Sean
[Music]
la la la la la